probably fine i could really use your
help
can we meet
just tell me when and where you don't
know how good it is to hear that
swing by the altical does cap i'll
explain it all the cow though
i thought you parted ways look it's a
long story
just hurry over i'm here
[Music]
[Music]
v it's good you're here
what happened spit it out the wraiths
took saul
the brick brain ventured out with a
small patrol and never came back
sure was race we've been observing their
camp
we know they're holding prisoners
including someone important
we need to free saul i don't know why
but
i felt i could count on you always pan
am
you and me are choose thought that was
clear
careful or i'll start believing that he
won't be able to get rid of me
i'll survive i'm sure whatever good will
you might feel
i'm sure you won't turn down one of the
best sniper rifles on the west coast
a tektronika grodd you saw it in action
already
that and the gratitude of the caldos
sounds fancy
once you have it in hand fancy all of a
sudden becomes kick-ass
let's go mitch we'll walk you through
the details well i'll be
pan m and v what's going on there
here after what happened to scorpion he
shows up here
i guess probably for saul ignore that
hey seriously you really aim to do this
someone has to you know you have a
piston missile right
someone has to
i want to give myself three to the point
where's mitch he was supposed to meet me
here he'll be here any minute
huh you never mention seeking outside
help
we can use all the help we can get
uh
foreign
okay how you want to do this quietly
an open assault would be suicide mitch
is already setting up the recon
you'll sneak into the race camp while i
cover you
going in quiet choose all you need it's
not that i don't want to go
to serve some raffins up some justice
it's just
look around the last attacks left barely
half of us standing
our supplies are stuck outside goddamn
reno and our gear
don't get me started we're up [ __ ] creek
static and i don't know if we're ever
gonna find or
fashion a paddle your leader gets nabbed
and you what
hope for the best rather not think about
what you do for the ones at the bottom
of your food chain
you're asking for trouble leave it he
has a right not to understand
there's mitch
i floated a drone over the wraith's camp
will you take a look or would you rather
keep mouthing off
let's see what we got here the raffins
can't see it
active camo but that practically inhales
battery shoes so make it quick
they found an abandoned cement plant to
squat in with a mass of heavy gear
locusts would be a better name for them
they fly into a place stupid of all it's
got then move on
but this time do you see the wall
they've added some primitive security it
points to them aiming to stay longer
the question is why who knows for sure
but i would guess that saul is part of
the reason
if he's still there we have to find a
way inside that guard post is probably
connected to the rest of the camp
our way in maybe but there are also
breeches in the wall
lightly guarded sections
[Music]
[Music]
straight to the point
someone has to you know you have a
piston missing right
someone has to
he'll be here any minute
never mention seeking outside help we
can use all the help we can get
up and adam
okay how you want to do this quietly
an open assault
it's not that i'd look around
we're up [ __ ] [ __ ]
so we do what saul would want us to do
we wait and get
there's mitch
hey there v i floated it we have live
let's see what we got here the raffins
can't
[Music]
they found an abandoned cement plant to
squat in with a massive heavy gear
locus would be a better name for them
they fly into a place
it of all its got then move on but this
time
do you see the wall they've added some
primitive security measures
it points to them aiming to stay longer
the question is why
who knows for sure but i would guess
that saul is part of the reason
if he's still there we have to find a
way inside that guard post is probably
connected to the rest of the camp
our way in maybe but there are also
breaches in the wall
lightly guarded sections
do you see the tracks
tire tracks their vehicles were moving
heavy freight
it could have been equipment either that
or saul's not their only prisoner
the tracks lead to the truck can you
scan it
that's probably the one that kept saul
in
the main building there saul must be
inside
quite a spread being like looking for a
diamond in a hailstorm
if they haven't scrapped and gutted the
place for parts you could access the
local cabinet
you would just need to find the control
room
oh
the skywalk it connects the garage to
the main structure
okay got some stuff to work with now
[Music]
yep let's go get saw perfect mitch is
the van primed
i did what i could take a tour
solid job i mostly improvised actually
either way it'll have to do
hold on a minute i got one more thing if
you find saul hasn't flatlined you'll
probably need this
spike super jet a rhino dose it should
speed up saul's central pump
hope so thought i could carry him out of
my back
so that should be everything v will you
ride with me
yeah of course i'm going with you okay
you take the wheel one me driving yep i
need to fiddle with my scope a bit
oh yeah we even have a radio in here
take it for a spin if you like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i still can't believe he let himself get
captured
anyone else
moving civilians across the border
during a bombardment
hijacking a petrochem tank opening the
valves
cranking a few figure eights to set the
desert
i know it's just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holy do you see that that is one hell of
a storm
looking bad oh it's bad in more than its
look
we have to move quickly
okay let's go over the plan again you
slip into the race cam
soft as a fox but if things get noisy
i'll be your long-distance insurance
policy will be linked at all times
so as soon as you find saul i'll fire up
the engine and we'll speed up
[Music]
[Music]
i still can't believe he let himself get
captured
anyone else says yourself he's not at
the top of his form
yes moving civilians across the border
during a bombardment
hijacking a petrochem tanker opening the
valves
cranking a few figure eights to set the
desert ablaze and give the kids a fun
show
that's that's all i remember all had our
idols
i know it's just
[Music]
i here
so
so
holy do you see that that is one hell of
a storm
looking bad oh it's bad in more than its
look
we have to move quickly
okay let's go over the plan
we need to hide the car park beside that
outcrop
okay out i'll find a place to roost and
keep you in sight
you just watch yourself down there
[Music]
all right i'm in position i have you in
range
so
oh
[Music]
okay you're near the main structure that
has to be where they're holding
themselves
okay main building watch
my phone remember what i told you
find the control room
damn it v so much for being slimed
[Music]
find saul and you two get out of there
oh yeah
ugh
feel the rush
uh
right now
playing
[Music]
here
you're just wasting your time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what are you fine get out of here
stay right where you are
hmm
finally some action
huh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
playing hide-and-seek now
huh
[Music]
that are not what i signed up for
[Music]
[Music]
that was not what i signed up for
[Applause]
right i think i got eyes on him
is he breathing i think so good
grab him and get out of there
do you have my goddamn
easy song i'm here with pan am
probably could use this
oh yeah so how is he time to don my
dancing shoes
he'll live now get yourselves out of
there
middle of a [ __ ] storm down here brewing
to be a category 5. i know get out of
the building i'll be right there
that's a mistake you'll regret
[Music]
all right
so
a mistake another one serious right now
those devils wanted to know our location
if we drive to camp now we'll just be
setting the table for you look outside
lately
the storm will wipe our tracks
[ __ ]
[Music]
we need to shake them
that's one way to treat an engine [ __ ]
off saul
i can't squeeze any more out of it cut
off that tail
[Music]
get ready all the cargo
the tall dogs
dammit we got more
[Music]
i'll get us there now
[ __ ] my head you have to kill me
all right
[Music]
i can't push
i need me an angle
already
this sort of stock down
that away girl couldn't have done it
better myself
hey thanks
[Music]
you see those buildings we'll wait it
out there
i remember this place it should be safe
at least for now
inside quick
i need to catch my breath
just in time for dinner not hungry
i just swallowed a pound of sand
looks like we're in for the night a
little power might be useful
could you help me look v i'll search in
here
a lot of useful things the angles left
in a hurry
biotechnica made them a good offer
here sell us your land
you don't know that
[Applause]
no bulldozers no backhoe loaders
everyone
damn it's getting cold
i tried to get us some heat in here no
luck
can you check it might have the magic
touch
actually you know what check the fuse
outside it might have come loose
if so just whack it back and place
oh
oh
see what i see expiration dates from
before the last war
so hopefully it hasn't turned to poison
today is our lucky day
lucky interesting choice of words do i
hear a lecture coming on
go on get off your feet it could be ours
no no lecture but we do need to talk
that rate's crap it shouldn't have
happened
they wanted everything our camp
locations
routes off loading points if they knew
what state we're in
one or two more raids and that'd be the
end of us and if you hadn't mounted a
rate of your own
well that would have been the end of me
see that clenched teeth furrowed brow
it's his way of saying thanks we've had
our spats
a few like any family they're not worth
digging up
i think so too if you'd like to come
back
everyone will be waiting arms open wide
but there will have to be changes no
more jumping to the front of the line
and so it begins you know what's coming
bigger [ __ ] problems maybe a war
we can't hope to handle the raffins
alone so you would sell us out to
biotechnica
vayne tell them it's a damn rotten idea
you gotta agree with pan am sounds like
a truly shitty idea
thanks what could you possibly know
about it
you know what i always liked about
nomads your taste
no your hunger for freedom it's not easy
to come by in night city
the corpse got their grubby claws and
everything and i just
can't believe you'd hand them what you
hold to be most precious
thank you v i could not have said it
better
you know what sweetheart we have plenty
of time to tear at each other's throats
later
that is my hope
but right now i wouldn't mind catching a
few wings
need help [ __ ] off
huh do you know what they call these
storms in north africa
i boobs damn i love that word
well what was that about
probably the meds talking i sure hope so
i think he took a few solid hits to his
skull
funny what is i rarely sleep with a roof
overhead
yet this will be the second time with
you when you're on the road day and
tonight
today your butt basically fusing with
your seat
you forget what it's like think this is
any better no
just different yeah this would make for
a decent little motel wouldn't it
a little fireplace booze grumpy guy at
reception is the one thing missing
have everything you need man
i couldn't ask for more
ma'am i'm sure you'd be cozier with your
shoes off
after a full day in them i'd fear a
health code violation
nonsense after a day as full as today
you deserve to kick back oh
and what did you have in mind
i got a few ideas i think you know what
kind
uh the
no it's really nice as is
let's not spoil it okay
i i'm sorry didn't know what i was
thinking oh it's fine
truly don't let it worry you right
so friends then b
i'm glad you came really thanks
it meant a lot to me
do you hear that
no
the wind has waned i can't speak for
haboobs but
when a chinook rolls rough and rowdy
across the plate
i sure can't get any should i
not awake
on behalf of the staff of the
independent california motel
i wish you all sweet dreams
[Music]
stars choomba
look who's alive hey
good just good work v old style raid
and you gotta agree now next time i
choose the motel
if there is such a time
well i slept like a puppy that's a cozy
shoulder you have there
it's too bad i better get rolling in a
minute
just not want to kick back and relax are
you
it's not my style no i'm back with a
clan
sure but i have things to do come on
last night when we were talking to saul
thanks for standing up for me though one
thing
the wraiths the raid it's the start of
something we need to prepare for
saul will get everything set up in camp
whereas
i whereas you
[Music]
the raffins wanted to know our roots
right well it's the aldi caldo's turn
some recon is in order one more thing
your compensation please take care of
her
she served me well
putting her in good hands i know
so uh thank you once again
uh hold up about last night
we don't need to talk about that i'm
just
not like that so what are you like
more like this
take care of yourself you too banan
and remember i'm indebted
circumstances were different i'd say
saddle up and right after her
but here and now just look
damn hard to catch a girl like that
only hope you've got as they feel a pain
and stop to wait
what's with you don't know a memory
maybe
don't matter okay
back to town v had it up to here with
this gusty outback